[MUSIC PLAYING]
Climate change has
actually already happened.
It's not something
that we can prevent,
at least fully at this point.
You saw this with
Hurricane Maria,
and most recently with
Hurricane Michael,
that we're just seeing more
intense and more frequent
giant storms.
My question as a researcher is
how can we develop technologies
that help people adapt
to this new environment?
Help people live in a
world that's already been
affected by climate change.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What people don't realize
is that a lot of this debris
is actually incredibly
energy-dense.
Just raw aluminum has 40
times the energy density
of lithium-ion and two times the
energy density of diesel fuel.
So the idea is to be able
to take a part of your house
that was broken, or a part
of your car-- like a wheel
that you can't use anymore--
and converting that
into fuel that can be used to
provide water and electricity.
So if your car was
destroyed by the hurricane,
I might cannibalize one wheel
of my car and my family of four
could have fresh water
for like three months.
Normally, if you take aluminum
and you expose it to water,
nothing happens.
And that's because there is a
protective oxide layer coating
the aluminum surface.
Turns out that if you
take these same BBs
and you apply a minimal
coating of gallium and indium
in the right
percentages, it actually
becomes super exothermically
reactive with water.
These little bubbles that
you're seeing are hydrogen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And actually at
this point I'm going
to stick it in the
fume hood here,
just because it's getting
a bit too hot to hold.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What I'm doing is
I'm using that energy
to desalinate water and
provide electricity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the desalinator.
There are no extra
components needed.
No electricity is required.
It has essentially
no moving parts.
This is an incredibly robust way
to produce clean water almost
immediately.
All of that hydrogen and
steam and heat that's produced
goes into generating really
high pressures in here.
It's about 2,000 PSI.
That pressure pushes
down this piston,
which forces seawater through
a semi-permeable membrane.
Oh, wow.
So it's a process
called reverse osmosis.
Right.
And then the really
cool thing is
that after I've desalinated
whatever volume of water
I want to desalinate, I
have all this hydrogen,
this pressurized
hydrogen, left over.
So what I do is I just
open up this valve
and I divert the hydrogen
into a fuel cell.
And now I have electricity.
Wow.
So there's still a ways
to go before you can just
take any old aluminum and
do what I'm saying here.
But in a lab, it
works totally great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]